hello and welcome i'm james murphy here
to tell you about the
beta release of python 3.10
as of may 3rd 2021 python 3.10 is now in
beta
that means from now until sometime in
october when it is actually
released there will be no new features
added to 3.10
it's only bug fixes from here on out so
it's especially important for viewers
like you
to try out 3.10 before it's actually
released
of course there are a ton of things that
have been changed in 3.10 and i'm not
going to go through all of them
i'm just going to go through the biggest
ones and the ones that really stand out
to me
of course in my opinion structural
pattern matching is the biggest most
important
new feature that's added in 310. i've
already made a whole video explaining
all the nitty-gritty details of
structural pattern matching
for that reason i'm not going to say
anything more about structural pattern
matching in this video
go watch my old video if you want to
hear about it to me
the remaining features fall into two
general categories
those that support the typing library
that help you write better
type hints and quality of life
improvements
this video is going to focus
specifically on everything related to
typing
the quality of life improvements and
other miscellaneous changes will be
covered in my next video
okay let's get started with typing first
up is pep 604 with the new
type union operator in the past it's
been a little bit annoying to work with
type unions
first i have to import the union from
the typing library
and then writing it this way just
doesn't feel very good
well from now on you can use the
vertical bar or pipe character
to denote the union of two types i no
longer need to import union from the
typing library
this syntax int pipe float is a synonym
for the union of int and float
in my opinion this is a welcome
improvement really encouraging people by
making it that much easier to type
things
next up is pep 612 with parameter
specifications
param specs are meant to help users type
hint
higher order functions similar to a type
variable
a param spec will match whatever
parameters of a function
are given this would allow you to say
take in any function
and return a function that has the same
signature here is an example of using a
param spec
from the pep we create a param spec just
like we do a type variable
we're going to write this function add
logging addlogging takes in a callable
and returns another callable with the
same parameters except the return type
has been changed to an awaitable of
r that means from this function we
return another function with
the same parameters as the original but
now the return
type is an awaitable of the original
because here we're using an await
keyword and an async function
notice here that we can now properly
type hint star
args and star star quarks to be p dot
args and p dot quarks
this way we can refer specifically to
the args and quarks of the original
function's parameters which were
captured by p
this means that whatever parameters the
passed in callable has
you can refer to its args and quarks by
accessing p.orgs and p dot quarks
here are some more examples of
signatures of functions that either add
remove or change parameters this
function add
takes in a callable with some parameters
that returns an int
and it returns a new callable that has a
new additional string parameter along
with all the other old parameters
additionally it now returns a bool here
we are using the newly introduced
typing.concatenate which can
only be used in this context as the
first argument in a callable
concatenate stir p means that the
parameters to this new function
should first be a string followed by all
the parameters that were passed into the
original function
we can use concatenate and paramspec in
the input of a function instead of the
output
to remove parameters instead of add them
here we're taking in a function which
takes an int
and some other stuff and returns a
function which just takes the other
stuff
no more int next on the list is pep 613
with
explicit type aliases if you have a
recursive data structure or a data
structure where you refer to the type of
the data structure
in one of the type hints in the data
structure you can't
use the actual type of the data
structure when you do that
this is because within the definition of
the data structure the data structure is
not yet defined so you can't use it
for this reason python allows you to use
strings that name
types instead of the actual types
themselves that part's not new
what is new is that now you can
explicitly mark a string as being a type
alias
meaning it shouldn't be used as just
another string object it should only be
used as a type hint
this is mainly to help type checkers
from getting confused between
global string declarations that might
look like types
and actual things that are supposed to
be types you would use a type alias in
much the same kind of situation that you
would use a forward declaration
in c or c plus plus you're essentially
telling the type checker
i'm going to define a type with this
name in the future
next up pep 647 with user defined type
guards
static type checking is fundamentally
limited in a dynamic language
there are some situations where a type
checker can infer
more information on a type based off of
what's around the statements
in this case val is an optional string
which means it's either a string or none
we check to see if val is not none
if thou isn't none then within this if
block we can assume that it's a string
type checkers today already do this
similarly in the else block we know that
it must be
none there are already a few cases where
type checkers can
narrow down the type based off of code
execution for instance you can narrow
down a union using an is instance check
or you can narrow down a literal by
using an equality check
but in some cases the type checker just
can't do it
in this case we go through a list of
objects and check to see if they're all
instances of strings if they're all
instances
of strings then this is a list of
strings and i should be able to join
that list
but type checkers aren't smart enough to
be able to figure this out
enter user defined type guards you take
as an argument
some object with some type hint the
return type of the function is labeled
as typeguard of something
what this actually means is that this
function returns a bool
that determines whether or not the input
is of the given type
so if this function returns true then
the type checker should assume
that val is actually a list of stir not
a list of object
if the function returns false then no
more information is gathered about the
type
if your function takes more than one
parameter the type guard only applies
to the first argument it says nothing
about the second or any other arguments
if your function is actually a method or
class method though
then it applies to the second argument
the one after self or class
finally there were some small changes to
how the typing literal works
literal no longer cares about duplicate
arguments or the order of its arguments
but it does now care about the type of
its arguments and whether or not its
arguments are hashable
okay that's all the taipin related
content that i could fit into one video
if i
left your favorite out then make sure to
post it in the comments
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
the next video on all the rest of the
improvements coming in python
go ahead and start beta testing